la coop 25 et qui aura connu les plus
longue prolongation de son histoire
prend fin avec un goût de déception
ayant été menotté et été noël polio
c'est triste de ne pas avoir été capable
d'en arriver à un accord final nous
étions si près du but explique la
présidente de la conférence
les discussions ont achoppé surtout sur
le choix il le financement de cib
ambitieuse et passion d'agir
les jeunes interpelle les décideurs nous
ne pouvons plus attendre que des enfants
d'aujourd'hui deviennent des adultes
pour prendre en main les changements
climatiques souligne d'activistes greta
tandberg
oui ce sont nous les peuples autochtones
qui protégeront les futures générations
dans cet activiste de 13 ans originaire
du canada et c'est la corde au cou que
plusieurs manifestants attire
l'attention sur l'urgence climatique
je crains que mon enfant connaisse un
jour la famine raconte cette
manifestante
[Applaudissements]
le message dans la vue est tout aussi
clair l'inaction des groupes pollueurs
comme le brésil la chine ou les états
unis ne passe pas un groupe d'activistes
a même déversé du fumier en guise de
protestation
au final les deux semaines de
négociations à madrid n'auront permis
que demain ce progrès alors que l'accord
de paris et ses objectifs entrerons dans
une phase cruciale l'an prochain un
accord fragilisé par l'annoncé du
retrait des états unis ici gabriel
proulx rate au canada montréal